[Music]
game of thrones made many household
names of its stars
however some have fallen off the map in
one way or another despite being touched
by the show's massive success
here's the cast members that took a
break from acting and why you haven't
seen much of them
since before game of thrones the child
actor jack gleason
was best known as a small boy with
impossibly large eyes in batman begins
in the first chapter of christopher
nolan's dark knight trilogy he shares a
brief adorable scene with the caped
crusader
a role credited as the little boy on the
balcony in 2011
gleeson was cast on game of thrones as
joffrey baratheon and quickly became the
character viewers loved to hate the most
we watched him grow from the whiny
spiteful and vengeful prince of the
seven kingdoms into the whiny spiteful
and vengeful king
of the seven kingdoms his selfish antics
caused the death of arya's friend the
butcher's boy
sansa's direwolf lady and eventually the
most shocking death of the first season
the execution of former hand of the king
ned stark
this would turn out to be the act of
cruelty that famously made it clear that
no one is safe from death on game of
thrones
not even the lead build actor in the
credits jack gleason's face would go on
to become the embodiment of evil for
many game of thrones fans
in yet another twist king joffrey dies
abruptly in season 4
at his own wedding as it turns out jack
gleeson was glad to leave the role
and start himself behind at the time he
told entertainment weekly
i've been acting since age 8. i just
stopped enjoying it as much as i used to
he since stayed active in the theater as
a producer co-funding the collapsing
horse theater company
and attended college at trinity
university in dublin
after leaving the show he only returned
to television for a brief role
on comedian sarah pascoe's series out of
her mind
even so that was just a sort of meta
commentary on the villainous role that
led him to turn away from the spotlight
isaac hempstead wright landed the role
of bran stark
in game of thrones at just 12 years old
his prior on-screen experience was a
small part in the horror movie
the awakening that had yet to be
released as bran
he arguably instigated a large portion
of the plot of the entire show
since his discovery of jamie and cersei
lannister's incestuous affair
this led to his serious fall thanks to
jaime which was the inciting incident
of the pilot the things i do for love
bran would go on to weave one of the
most unique journeys through westeros
over the course of the show paralyzed
from the waist down
he learns to adapt to his new life just
in time to escape to the north when
winterfell is captured by theon greyjoy
he then hones his ability to warg into
his dire wolf
and is eventually trained by a mystical
man known as the three-eyed raven
in the art of green sight which
essentially means having visions of the
past
this enables him to discern the game of
thrones twist that most of the audience
saw coming from a mile away
that is jon snow's true parentage as an
heir to the iron throne in a shocking
turn that even hempstead wright thought
was a joke at first
bran ends up on the throne at the
story's end he also winds up with a
mouthful of a title
as tyrion says in full bran the broken
the first of his name
king of the andals and the first men
lord of the six kingdoms and protector
of the realm isaac hempstead wright
meanwhile was struggling to find
normalcy behind the scenes while his
alter ego took such strange turns
on a huge hit tv show he told esquire uk
that game of thrones all but ruined his
college experience he shared
my address got published i couldn't walk
out of my halls without having to take a
selfie
eventually i got assigned a campus
police officer
he dropped out but eventually returned
to university college london to study
neuroscience
focusing on his studies he naturally
took a break from acting until appearing
in a minor role
in the 2021 film voyagers in april
of 2021. jacob anderson gained
prominence with recurring roles on
broadchurch and episodes before landing
the role of grey worm
as the elected leader of the unsullied a
group of eunuch warriors raised his
slaves
he displays a fierce devotion to
daenerys targaryen for freeing him
and all of his brethren he chooses to
fight for her as one of her most trusted
lieutenants
eventually he has time amidst all the
late season chaos for a doomed romance
with daenerys advisor
missandei in sales with the remaining
unsullied missandei's homeland
at the end of the series anderson didn't
do much other acting during his time on
game of thrones
and hasn't appeared on screen since the
series ended but don't worry that
casting directors are giving this
talented actor the cold shoulder
he stepped out of the film and
television spotlight because he's
focusing on his music career
as a pop and r b singer known as raleigh
richie
few characters during all of game of
thrones were more compelling
and few deaths more heart-wrenching than
shireen baratheon
the only surviving child of stannis
baratheon she's treated coldly by her
father as he pursues the iron throne
after his brother's death
she doesn't get any more warmth from her
mother who resents her for being
partially disfigured from a disease
known as grayscale she finds comfort
however in her friendship with the kind
sir davos
who is in her father's service shireen
even demonstrates ingenuity at multiple
points that aids her father in his
various battles and quests
across the series ultimately however
he's convinced by the sorceress
melisandre
during a desperate moment that a
sacrifice of king's blood
will help turn the tide in his favor and
shireen is his only option
in a scene that many fans found
unnecessarily cruel poor shireen is
burned alive as her mother cries in
anguish and stannis looks away in tears
this show
really could get pretty dark when it
wanted to the english actress carrie
ingram brought shereen to life and
unlike her on-screen counterpart she
remains thankfully alive and well
already the winner of an olivier award
for starring in matilda the musical
before game of thrones
she made a few other tv appearances she
was actually a series regular
on free reign during the run of thrones
but hasn't had any appearances since it
ended
in 2019 the pandemic likely played a
role
but we'll surely be hearing from carrie
ingram in the future
luke barnes is primarily a british
playwright and screenwriter with only a
single acting role as drunk man
in an episode of skins to his name
before playing rast on game of thrones
nevertheless he left an indelible mark
as one of several unsavory villains that
jon snow encounters during his time at
castle black with a nice watch
rast is a foul criminal that took the
black and pledged service
the night's watch instead of a worse
punishment he torments jon's friend sam
during training and acts clearly envious
of jon's skill
an increasingly prominent role as the
months pass
he stabs the honorable lord commander
mormont in the back
during the mutiny at craster's keep and
later even tortures
poor hodor when the mutineers briefly
detain him
along with bran stark his eventual death
at the pause of jon snow's direwolf
ghost is one of several very satisfying
ones
over the course of this extremely
death-friendly show
after wrapping his time on game of
thrones barnes did have a couple small
parts in short films
but hasn't appeared on screen since the
show ended instead he's returned to his
native northern ireland to focus on
writing and producing theater once more
like many of the other child actors on
game of thrones ben hockey had just a
few small roles
before appearing as hot pie friend of
arya stark
an orphan who's been sent to the night's
watch when they meet he bonds with arya
as well as gendry
when they're waylaid by lannister forces
and held prisoner at harrenhal
eventually they escape only to be
captured by the brotherhood without
banners and escorted to the inn at the
crossroads
there hot pie finds a rare happy ending
for a minor game of thrones character
he becomes a baker's apprentice taken on
by the owner of the end to bake bread
he even gives arya a loaf of bread
shaped like a dire wolf
as a goodbye present then haki hasn't
been seen acting
on screen since his time on game of
thrones although he has apparently
turned his role as hot pie
into a new real-life business as
reported by us weekly
he's partnered with a uk delivery
service to bring the direwolf bread to
the public with a business
incredibly named you know nothing john
doe
british actor stephen cole was primarily
known for five years on the long-running
liverpool soap opera
brookside playing leo johnson from 1996
to 2001.
this was before being cast as kovaro in
season 2 of game of thrones in 2012.
after the death of khal drogo at the end
of season 1 kovaro becomes one of
daenerys targaryen's most trusted blood
riders as she navigates the desert of
the red waste and the treacherous city
of qarth after playing a semi-prominent
part in that storyline in season 2
however
cavarro never appears again for
unexplained reasons
stephen cole would have minor parts in
2014
and 2018 but has yet to act since game
of thrones ended in 2019
it's not known if the pandemic or
personal reasons have kept him off
screens
out of a cast of hundreds it's possible
there's at least one that just has bum
luck
last but not least we have arguably the
biggest villain of the entire
show the night king commanding an army
of white walkers
whites and eventually even his own
dragon the night king slowly and surely
marches south to invade westeros
don't be afraid this culminates with the
epic battle
in the season 8 episode the long night
though the night king was originally
played by character actor
richard brake he left the show after
season six due to a scheduling conflict
he was replaced by stuntman
vladimir furtick for season seven and
eight it probably helped the transition
that the character's face is a
combination of makeup and cgi
and he also never speaks furtick has
been a stuntman for decades in hollywood
working on movies like dragon heart
behind enemy lines and thor the dark
world
in addition to appearing in five
episodes as the night king he worked as
a stunt performer
on 16 episodes of game of thrones as
well he was also credited as a stunt
supervisor on the episode winterfell
he continues his work as a stunt
performer on the netflix series the
witcher
but the night king remains his last
credited on-camera role
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one